so these workers are the next group to
become eligible in the front line
essential workforce lane
orc o mana joining us now live on the
strip with their reaction tonight orca
well denise and brian casino workers
here on the las vegas strip
and restaurant employees across town
have been waiting for this moment for
months
their jobs require them to come into
close contact with people
but now the vaccine means extra
protection against covet 19.
i have been a dealer for 30 years robin
mcdermott works in one of the casinos on
the las vegas strip her interactions
with gambling guests a concern amid the
coronavirus
you're at the casinos dealing with
people from everywhere
so you never know who you're coming into
contact with
and how you know things are going to
happen
to you and taking it back to your family
but hospitality workers in clark county
are now
eligible for the covet 19 vaccine we
should have been offered it sooner
but glad that we finally do get it the
local culinary union encouraging
everyone to get vaccinated especially
because more than 100 of its members and
their relatives have died of kovid since
last march
we know the only way we're going to
protect our family we're going to
protect
ourselves if most of the people get in
the vaccine
workers at clark county restaurants like
crazy peta are also now able to get the
shot and even with safety measures in
place
owner maddie zarlul tells me the vaccine
will bring more peace of mind
we just we see the the light in the
tunnel that
soon that all this will be behind us and
we move on with our normal lives
and that's what casino workers are
hoping for too make ourselves
a little bit safer and stop being this
virus
the workers i spoke to also say they're
happy to be eligible now
because capacity limits are set to
increase to 50 percent in just
four days to schedule an appointment
head to the southern nevada health
district's website
we also have a link on our website eight
newsnow dot com
reporting live on the las vegas strip
tonight orca mana 8 news now